- [Instructor] Let's say
that we want to figure out
what is seven and 11/12
minus one and 6/12.
Pause this video and see
if you can figure that out.
All right now let's work on this together.
So there's a couple of ways
that you could approach this.
You can view this as the same
thing as seven plus 11/12
and then minus one and you
might be tempted to say minus
one and then plus 6/12 but
remember you're subtracting
not just the one you're
subtracting one and you're
subtracting 6/12 so minus one minus 6/12.
Now why is that useful to
think about it that way?
Well now you can think about
the whole numbers so you can
say this is going to be
seven minus one plus 11/12,
plus 11/12 minus 6/12, minus 6/12.
And so seven minus one is six,
so it's going to be six plus
now if I have 11 of
something in this case 12ths
and I'm subtracting six of
them away six of the 12ths,
I'm gonna be left with five of
those somethings, five 12ths.
So it's going to be six plus
5/12 which is the same thing
as six and 5/12.
Now as you get more used
to this you could do some
of this maybe even in your
head, you could say hey look,
look at the whole number
parts, seven minus one is going
to give me six and then
if I say 11/12 minus 6/12
is going to give me 5/12 so
that takes up a little bit
less space.
Another way that you might
see this approached is you can
rewrite this as seven and 11/12
minus, minus one and 6/12.
Let me do the 6/12 in that
blue color that I'm using
for the fraction parts,
6/12 and then I would first
focus on the fractional parts
and I'd say 11/12 minus 6/12
is 5/12 and seven minus one
is six and I got six and 5/12.
So many different ways to
approach the same thing
and at the end of the day
they really are the same
underlying idea.